There are a few more methods that D3 defines on a selection object that allow
you to transform and mutate DOM nodes.
If you're curious about all the possible options,
I suggest reading through D3's API docs on their site, or
by simply exploring the selection objects using Chrome's autocomplete.
In this case,
I'm going to store the return value of the selection into a variable header.
And now with my header dominoed, I can try to call a function on it and
see what the Chrome console tries to autocomplete.
Calling header dot shows not only the functions D3 defines but
any function I could possibly call on the object I'm working with.